comment est né le livre vous êtes dit il
faut absolument qu'on raconte notre
histoire
on va se mettre face à face et tous se
raconter c'est comme ça que ça s'est
construit on avait envie de dire on a
vraiment des délits par leur donne
vraiment envie de faire quelque chose
ensemble françoise et moi et puis on
s'est dit pourquoi est ce qu'on ferait
pas un livre parce qu'on a toujours été
des grandes amoureuses de livres à
l'émoi et puis on s'est dit halliche sur
quoi et à ce moment là d où venait
d'arriver dans la vie de françoise de
son petit dernier qui a eu deux ans y'a
pas longtemps et tout d'un coup j'étais
apte ont tué deux garçons dont sur son
j'ai deux filles
tu es tout seul avec eux je suis tout
seul avec elle et bah on va dire qu'on
peut avoir des enfants qui peuvent être
heureux et qu'en plus les mères peuvent
être heureuses parce que c'est quand
même ça le but de la vie quoi hein
et alors on a pensé faire un livre de
conseils pour les femmes qui élevé seuls
leurs enfants n'a proposé saad nous
éditrice chez isabelle laffont chez
lattès isabelle nous a dit vont coûter
et conseille les femmes n'ont pas besoin
quand elles ont des enfants qu'elle doit
les aider tout seul elle se débrouille
mais des clair que ça peut être ma foi
joyeux plutôt dramatique
alors on s'est attelé à la tâche et on a
fait ce livre qui est un peu un
témoignage et qui a été écrit un peu
1,80 et en plus aveugle c'est ça qui
était plus rigolo c'est que sur les
souvenirs d'enfance
on a écrit chacune de notre côté sans
dire quel souvenir on avait sélectionné
les secrets de révéler quand même moi
j'ai découvert des choses sur les
mauvais exemple aux bas par exemple à
quel point toute petite elle avait une
conscience aiguë et de ce qu'elle
faisait avec moi c'est à dire sa
tyrannie de grande soeur qu'elle ne m'a
jamais avoué le première blessure
qu'elle n'avait jamais alors et dans
l'avenue louis et à quel point j'étais à
importante pourrait croire qu'elle m'a
jamais dit non plus mais donc voilà donc
c'est des révélations et puis des
connivences encore plus fort
m